Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Spotify is making it easy for you to stream this
podcast and many others like it on your mobile device or your desktop app or
your smart speaker. Just open the app on your mobile device or your desktop.
Click on the browse channel and then click the podcast section and stay
entertained with Spotify today.
Oh wait, you're letting
you are listening to radio lab radio lab
from [inaudible], w.
N. Y. S. E. N. N. P. E. R. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab,
the podcast and today on the podcast something a little different. We,
we say that often we do. This is more different than our usual different, yeah.
This is a comes from our friend Carl Zimmer who's been on the show a bunch of
times, helping us untangle some complicated scientific things.
This time we find him not in our normal area in our show.
He's in the basement of a bar, which is in Brooklyn, New York to untangles.
Really kind of a very personal question in his mind. I want to give it away.
That's right. Carl told this particular story for a group called story collider,
which has people come on stage to live stories about science.
And the fellow you're going to hear introducing Kraut. This is Ben Lilly,
welcome to the stage. Carl Zimmer. He's the Co founder Co founder story,
correct?
Yeah.
So in 1997,
I woke up in the middle of the night in South Sudan. Uh,
at the time, uh, South Sudan was not its own country.
It is an independent country. Uh, just recently when I was there,
um, it was in the middle of a civil war. Now,
South Sudan as a territory is about the size of Texas and I was not near the
front lines. So, uh,
it's not as if I had to worry about getting shot by somebody from the other
side. But there were plenty of things to be very worried about. So, for example,
if you were walking around outside and there was a plane coming overhead,
you never quite knew if it was a plane that came from Khartoum where that had a
bomb and was looking for a place to drop it and they like to drop it on places
like hospitals, which is where I was at. Um,
and if the bombs didn't get you, there were lots of other things that could,
little invisible things that could get you, um, see,
because South Sudan is at the time,
was probably the best place in the world to get sick.
There were so many ways to get sick and so many ways you could still get sick
and South Sudan you actually really couldn't get sick anywhere else in the
world. Um, so for example,
there were flies buzzing around called cc flyers and they might bite you and
they might put a little single celled parasite into you and you would get
sleeping sickness. Uh,
you can't really get sleeping sickness much of any place else. Uh,
and if you didn't get medical attention, you would die.
It's one of those diseases where there's, there's no escape clause.
You will die if you don't get medicine. And in, in that case,
the medicine that you would get was basically arsenic.
So neither, uh, alternative is really attractive. Um,
then maybe you would drink some unfiltered water and you might swallow a Guinea
worm. So you might swallow some invisible, uh, larvae. Uh, it would, uh,
get into your stomach and say, well, this is where I belong. It would grow.
It would burrow out of your, uh, out of your intestinal wall.
It would wander around in your abdomen.
It might meet up with the Guinea worm of the opposite sex,
and they would mate and the chemo would develop eggs. Yeah.
You know where this is going. She gets to be about two feet long.
She says it's time to bring forth a new generation of Guinea worms.
What shall I do? I'm going to crawl down this person's leg
and I'm going to create a blister.
I'm going to poke up on skin criticalist blister,
which the only way to relieve it is to splash water on it.
And with every splash of water, the Guinea worm will Serge out eggs.
Then we'll go into another pond and carry on the generation of,
of getting worms.
So you might want to just pull on this thing and get the hell the thing out.
But of course you just pulled part of it and the rest would die.
And you would have about maybe a foot of dead worm in your leg and you would
probably have an immune reaction that would kill you.
There were things you could get sick of that had no name. You might survive,
you might not. Um,
and of course there were the good old standard ways to get sick. I mean,
there was malaria. You can get malaria in lots of places.
But the people at this medical center, they were, a lot of them were, um,
American doctors who would kind of go from crisis to crisis. Uh,
and, uh, they would talk about the malaria in South Sudan and say, this is,
this is amazing malaria.
It was like the worst Valarie in the world. You know,
this is going military good. Those you don't just get a fever.
And kick kind of Achy and get over it. You go straight to your brain,
you go crazy. And if you don't get a plane,
a whole plane to get you out of there and maybe to Nairobi,
you're going to die.
Now something to bear in mind is that I'm not a doctor.
In fact, at this point I was kind of a hypochondriac
and so the thing is that like, you know, every time I got a fever,
I'm sure it was going to be meningitis or if I got a pain in my side,
I was sure it was going to turn into a tumor. Uh,
and so there I am, you know,
looking up in the moonlight and the mosquito netting above my head and I'm
saying holes in it. I'm thinking, what am I doing here?
This is the kind of trouble that writing about science can get you into
[inaudible]. I started as a copy as a science writer actually as a copy editor.
I got a job at a magazine. It was basically to pay the bills.
I was a copy editor. I wasn't very good at it. I would like commas go through,
which you're not supposed to do as a copy editor,
a as real copy editors will tell you, my boss took pity on me and you know,
let me fact check some things and I got to write a some short pieces just about
all sorts of different things, you know,
a moon of Saturn or beetle that produced a green glow.
And it was all interesting,
but it didn't feel particularly important to me. Um, you know,
I, I was always writing and I felt like when I grow up,
I'm going to be a writer,
but I wasn't really sure what I was going to be writing about. Um,
and so I got this job and it,
and it paid the bills and it was fine and eventually I would figure things out.
I hoped. Now, uh,
at the time I was dating a woman named Esther and so Esther and I had met in
high school and she was tough and she was funny and she wasn't quite sure what
she was going to do with her life when she grew up. Um,
and we managed to continue to date through college.
And then after college she really wanted to do something. And again,
she wasn't sure what, so she applied for the Peace Corps and she got in,
uh, and eventually she was assigned to Africa. But the whole process,
it takes an incredibly long time to actually even leave the United States.
So by the time she left,
I was already working at this job and I was already starting to write about
science. So she went to Rwanda.
And like, as it happens with a lot of people, that peace corps, she burned out.
So within a year she was back home, but she had gotten the bug.
She wanted to get back to Africa.
She wanted to be back there in a meaningful way.
And so she thought that a meaningful way to be there would to go as a journalist
to be a foreign correspondent.
So she applied to journalism school and she went to Columbia.
So Columbia was hard naturally. Um,
but after a while other things became to be hard.
So for example, waking up in the morning was hard.
And after a while, eating was hard.
And after a while,
walking up the stairs to our apartment was hard and she was asking what's going
on. So she went to her doctor and the doctor said,
something's wrong.
And eventually it was determined that she had a rare form of cancer that starts
in the pancreas.
Now you don't think about cancer when you're mid twenties. Uh,
you don't think of rare forms, the pancreas in your mid twenties. Uh,
and so as a result,
this cancer had moved really fast and spread very far by the time it was
detected. Now she and I, you know,
being in her mid twenties, we just thought, well,
we're gonna fight this as if somehow our thoughts could vaporize cancer cells.
Um, and our doctor kind of went along with that, I think,
because he probably felt that, you know,
maybe that's the best way that people in their mid twenties should deal with
something like this to prepare for a life that they're not going to have.
So, uh, after a few months, she died,
can I lid?
So I went away for a few months. Uh,
and then I came back and I came back to my job and I was writing about science
and it was different. So for example,
I wrote a story about water just about water. Um,
and yet it was quite mesmerizing to me.
Um, this was a story just about sort of how water molecules kind of interact.
They, they,
the kind of like dancers at a dance party in a crowded club and you know, the,
the volunteers sort of joined together and then pull apart,
they form clusters that dissolve again. And it's, it's, it's,
it's incredibly complicated and incredibly beautiful and it's water.
It's water that we've all grown up with looking at in a glass or what have you
and those water molecules, in a weird way.
I've been waiting all this time for us to understand them and to get to know
them. And I felt,
and talking to these scientists that in a way, uh,
you know what it was like this, this old friend.
So you know how like with an old friend,
you know you haven't seen him for a long time and you take up right where you
left off while these water molecules were just floating around for billions of
years,
just waiting for us to learn about them and we could go away and then we could
come back and maybe some scientists had found something else interesting about
water and it,
we would just take off where we left off and all the attention that we paid to
the water would be repaid with beauty.
So at the same time I looked at sort of all of us and human life and I felt
like, how is that a week?
And I'll be walking around just pretending that we are going to die.
You know, that maybe tomorrow you'll get a diagnosis and that's it. No, we're,
we're, we are, we're all gonna die. And so I, I felt like somehow like,
you know, we were walking,
all of us were like walking on a thin sheet of glass with cracks in it.
And I was the only one that noticed and I could look down and I could see the
people,
the other side that my doctor at the time I was actually friends with and,
and he was incredibly patient with me because he understood what sort of,
you know, that my frame of mind. And I would go to him and I would say,
all right, I don't want you to give me,
I want you to get tested my heart and I want you to test my blood.
I want you to test this and test that. As I said,
I was sure that if we ran enough tests that I would find out that there was
something wrong with me because I had to be right.
And so he would run test after test after test to become totally uncalled for.
Um,
and it all came back negative and I was so dissatisfied.
I was in perfect health and it was terrible.
Um,
so I think through that kind of experience, I,
I ended up writing a lot about evolution because here was a process where life
and life turning into death could actually not just end in death but lead to
something, uh, and you could produce new things.
So my first book, which came out a few years after Esther died, was,
was about evolution. And it was about these big transitions,
these transformations, um, you know,
fish coming on land and then some mammos going into the water becoming dolphins
and whales. And there was a certain kind of, um,
joy and melancholy and writing about it. I found this,
this passage from the metamorphosis by Arvin.
I made the, the EPO, the, uh, the opening to the book,
and the, the, the story is that, uh, you know, so the,
the metamorphosis is full of all sorts of changes, a lot of which are,
are very agonizing to the, the people who are going through those changes.
They don't like it. Um, and yet something beautiful comes out of it.
So, for example, the God Bacchus is, uh,
kidnapped by some people on a ship and he's going to take vengeance on them.
And so the sailors are horrified and watch their hands disappearing and turning
into just flippers and their nose stretches out into a hook and their voice
disappears and they're flailing around and they just leap into the water and
they become the whole fence. And I was reading that and I would think, you know,
I've seen that kind of changed myself in my own life.
After that book, I, I, uh,
was casting around for another idea and I thought, well,
I'll write about parasites. Um, and you know,
at the time it just sort of seemed like, oh, that'd be cool.
When I look back at it, I think there's something more going on there. I mean,
I became a real FSC Nado of the, the, the, the strangest,
most extreme parasites out there. I mean,
we're talking about wasps that perform brain surgery on cockroaches and then lay
their,
their eggs inside of them and the cockroaches are alive as the wasp is growing
inside them. Or, you know,
an aunt that climbs up to the top of, of a, of a flower,
and then a giant stock of fungus comes out of its head and showers down on the
aunts below sowing death.
And I suppose I just felt like, well, you know, if we're, hey,
we're all going to die,
you might as well look at the most amazing ways that,
that happens in the natural world.
So I started to travel around and look for parasites and I wanted to go to a
place where I could see parasites, uh,
making life difficult for people. I wasn't quite sure how to do it.
I had an old, really good friend who was living in Nairobi at the time,
so I went and visited him and his wife and I would make little forays to try to
find a story for my book.
And I just started, I ended up with a lot of dead ends and I was thinking,
you know, I'm going to go home and I'm going to have nothing.
It's going to be a real bummer. But my friend started by chance that, hey,
you know what? There's this medical organization,
they're dealing with the sleeping sickness epidemic in South Sudan at which is
actually right across the border from Kenya. And they're looking, you know,
they're,
they would like to invite some journalists to come and see what they're up to.
And to me this was, I don't know,
this was like the invitation for the Oscars or something.
I mean I was thinking of all the things that I could see there that I just read
about. I mean I could see them and so for example,
there's something called Loa loa. I don't know if any of you heard of it.
So it's a, it's a worm, a, if I remember correctly,
it's transmitted by mosquito. So you see a mosquito buzzing around, you think,
Oh God, I hope it didn't have low,
low and I hope it's not going to bite me because what happens, it bites you.
Lolo it gets into your system and it starts started crawling around and I'd like
to crawl around and connective tissue and one of the places where we have
connected tissue is in the surface of your eyes.
So, so people who get low, low,
I will say that they can actually see the parasite and crawling across their
field of you. So this was really a place where you could see parasites.
I mean really, really see them.
And I don't know if that meant that I wanted to get it or talk to someone and
say, well what's it like to see it? I don't know what I wanted.
All I know is that very early one morning I went to this little airport in the
outskirts and never go be with my friend. He drove me out there and you know,
then my friend Scott said, okay, I'll see ya. We Kinda,
I got in a little plane with a couple of other journalists and um, you know,
in order to, it's not easy to get into South Sudan,
especially back then when it was a war zone.
So what you had to do was you had to fly from Nairobi to the border and the is
like the most desolate place you can imagine.
You can look from miles and see basically nothing there may,
I think I saw a couple huts like in the distance that was it.
You land on one runway and there's another plane there that's the plan is going
to take you to South Sudan. So I'm like, okay,
I get my bag and I get out and other journalists are getting out there just like
four or five of us and there's no one else around for miles except this guy.
Um,
I recall he was wearing like a members only jacket and he was like the border
guard. Uh, and he said,
I would like to see your passports so you know,
you give me your passport because he's,
he's supposed to stamp them and giving them back to you and then you're on your
way, you know. But you know,
going across borders in Africa is always a little sketchy.
So you're nervous already. You're not because you know,
he holds your life in your hands. Maybe you want some money or something.
Well the thing was that he couldn't stamp a visa and her passport,
cause we weren't going to a real country. We weren't really going anywhere.
We're going to this place that had really no official designation yet.
So he didn't stamp our pieces. He just said, I'm going to hold onto these.
So he takes our passports and it just tucks him away in his members only jacket
and we're thinking, yes, we're going. And we all got into,
this plane was a supply plane.
There were some crates with medical supplies and stuff in it.
And we got in sort of buckle up along the walls of this open,
uh,
open a part in the back and they closed the back of the plane and then the plane
took off and we went off the grid.
So a week later I did come back and I did get my passport.
I did get back home. Uh, it's been 14 years since I got here,
back from South Sudan. Uh,
two years after I got back,
I fell in love with a woman named grace and we got married.
We have two girls who run around in our garden and I feel like I have been given
like a gift, a second life. A second story. Um,
[inaudible] we still deal with some parasites where I live. Uh,
maybe not getting worms, but you know, West Nile virus, Lyme disease,
it's actual plasma. You can never get away from them. Totally. You know,
we are human. Um, but I don't go to places like South Sudan anymore.
Mainly for their sake.
When I was there in South Sudan, I saw, um,
I saw a lot of things, you know,
I saw people separating beyond what I can imagine.
I also saw,
I saw a lot of people getting off their lives in the middle of a war zone,
which was something that I didn't even think possible. Uh,
before then I would see huge fields full of gigantic termite mounds.
But the thing that I actually remember most, most clearly was that night,
waking up in the middle of the night and looking up in a panic at that mosquito
net and thinking there are holes in it.
I could see them in the moonlight and I was,
I could feel this kind of panic coming up with me.
And then another voice in me said, well, what's the big deal? All right.
I mean,
if you're going on and on about how we're all going to die and you know there's
nothing you can do about it and you're sure that there's,
there's something just waiting for you,
then why didn't you just go back to sleep and just let it happen?
And I could feel, I could feel this, this thing inside me,
this thing inside me that was resisting that and that was me.
It wasn't a parasite that was myself.
And there was this drive that I felt I was not going to just fall asleep again.
You know, we are then. It's a drive that we all have, you know, we, we live,
we keep living. If death comes into the neighborhood,
we're going to fight it. And that is true. That's a rule and it's real.
It's as real as those water molecules floating in space for billions of years.
And that is what writing about science has given me. Thanks
[inaudible] on number line.
That's our podcast for today.
Thanks so much for listening and big thanks to the Ben Lillian story,
collider for letting us run that story. And of course to Carl Zimmer.
And by the way, a straight clutter has its own podcast. So if you,
if you like Carl story,
there's tons of more science stories that you can enjoy over there.
And the address is one word story,
collider.org I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening.